We've seen two methods for expanding
our ability to do segmentation.
One was the new method,
the new algorithm of finding modes
within some feature space and that,
and it was you know, didn't require
you to know the number of modes to begin
with, and all those other properties.
And then in some sense, more
importantly, no not more importantly,
in addition, we found a way of expanding
our feature space to include something
that describes texture.
And what you did was you created
a big t, feature vector,
texture feature vector at every point,
and
you would cluster that to get
these keywords or these textons.
And then you would, for every region,
you would get a histogram.
And then you would cluster based
upon those histograms, and
that's what gave you your segments.
Combined, these gives us
a pretty powerful method.